my game is sort of a London yours was
only true London and his was like a
veresov yeah D for what move order do
you play - a 4 D 5 okay before our
Bishop sat for Bishop before
good night f6 let's turn off stock - 9 6
9 f3 okay
c5 III knight c6 okay this position
we'll get into again yes and you just
forgot no I just
I actually just I meant to move it I
actually wanted to put my bishop on to
d3 but yes I did forget about the night
- yeah so if you play Bishop d3 right
away I think he pushes and then I bring
it back right well you could yeah that's
that's how I like to play because then
it gets been to a stone wall structure
I'm used to mmm but my BD - is like the
most precise yeah yes 100% it completely
and I think this would have thrown him
off because if he like if he's used to
playing Queen b6 yeah and then you take
yep you wouldn't be used to this
position and if this happens again yeah
we looked at this yesterday at the
uptake works over they probably won't
take on b2 if they're not familiar okay
so they could do a few other things I
think it would be happy here they could
take on c5 and I wouldn't be fine with
that yeah but there's a really nice move
for one here a 3 mm simply preparing be
folder and name it and then you want to
play c4 and you actually it's more of a
Queen's Gambit where blacks queen is
just terribly misplaced okay
I had this position good number of times
a bishop g4 like before Queen b6 e for
this is fun it's equally so okay yeah
just ya know the other thing he could do
if you play might be t2 he might start
thinking and then develop the bishop to
like at 5 or g4 right um and there's
tricky ways to play against both of
these moves if he plays Bishop a5 it's
actually really nice for what you just
take upon okay I mean it's a hard time
defending like he can't play e5
you lazy six uh you can just defend like
93 yeah that's what I was looking at and
it's c5 pawn okay like a five you
probably have a four and then like the
idea is Bishop e5 my very core
especially gets to alright well let's
get back to the game um yeah I'm just
saying if yes yes yes and then if you
plays Bishop g4 you can just play c3
okay and like then you're ready to do
exactly what I want
yeah okay so you played Bishop e2 Bishop
to I think it's still playable in place
of Queen b6 I played b3 I was even
debating here putting my knight to be
two might be to d2 keeping up this might
need you to or take my pawn or taking
the pawn and then nicely to the problem
with that it's very similar to other
line only you would have this move
Bishop e2 rather than being able to play
Bishop b5 in one move mm-hmm I mean he
could probably pick Queens e3d and then
I would just Castle queenside or kinks
wait and I take e5 wait what I take you
five that's probably true if it helps I
wouldn't have seen this I would I would
have gutted it to the point how we got
in there don't get me wrong
yeah okay there's actually a cool move
after Bishop e2 Queen b6 mmm that's very
tricky London type move Knight c3 okay
you defend the pawn with tactics because
you can't take because Knight d5 I'm
righteous wins right if you're either
chopping the Queen room xe7 unstoppable
so I'd c3 would have been tricky and
you're threatening night like you're
threatening to win with Mike beef I
think that just because it was a new
opening for me
I just needed it's difficult to find
this move without having seen it many
times before yeah and I mean almost
always in London you put your palm on c3
okay okay b3 so you're still doing okay
yeah so sorry
and then Bishop f5 okay I castled so
what I was really concerned about him
was his knight coming in and maybe
fooling around with my siste with my C
pawn no no Knighton's oh yes mm-hmm it's
not a huge concern because he's not
fully developed like worst-case scenario
plate you played night a3 or 91 okay or
even Bishop to e3 yeah like there's so
many moves to meet think before if he's
gonna play Knight a lot I think what I
was then feeling like if I was doing any
of those moves I was dropping my pawn on
the defiled the pawns defended three
times and only attacked twice
all rights attacked three times well if
he moves his Knight
oh if he moves his neither that's attack
twice okay so like oh jeez okay my
intention was to move the knight over to
the h2 - oh you want to place yeah I
wanted his well it depends on strike it
does yeah so I was very much he's trying
to get I'll try and get my king save
yeah and then like and then I would
figure it out from here yeah I mean this
is so fun okay so then after i castled
he went east six h3 okay just safety
square for mighty strong Bishop I just
wanted to get my position into like
equal as much as possible Bishop to e7
c3 and then h6 okay so he's also prevent
or he's preparing for an ith for right
but I wasn't sure if he was making his
if he was and that was my plan sure but
I wasn't sure if he was gonna Castle
queenside or Kings side right so I'm
also like waiting here a little ooh
I'm just doing my way castling queenside
is not usually good for black especially
in the London because like your bishop
cuts through the position and you have
breaks on the Queen side I understand
but it would have
throw me off that I would add deal with
a pawn storm potentially yeah like he
might
yeah he's maybe making you think about
exactly so that's what I was waiting for
that was my intention with h3 originally
uh-huh so not just a safety square but I
had planned to put my Bishop on h2 and
then pawn storm mm-hmm
so c3h6 knight Knight B to d2 and then
he went castle mm-hmm Knight e5 good
move rook F to D 8 and then Bishop to h2
and so this is when I was kind of happy
for a brief moment yeah I think it's a
solid position
I have weaknesses of course on the Queen
side but I thought if I've made
maneuvers on the Kings side I would put
the pressure back right on him the prime
is that he's got pieces over there and
so I wanted to redirect his pieces over
to the Queen side before I did
everything on the Kings side right
there's a few like this is very typical
for a London structure oh really but
there's a few good things about black
compared to normal structures a normal
structure you would still have your pawn
on B - exactly
and his Bishop is sometimes behind - yep
behind so black has more possibilities
make sense - it's the same theory with
Stovall I assure you but yeah you still
have your play of like a for g4 so
that's what I was looking at and I
didn't know when to do it and I think I
waited too long okay so that that became
the problem is that I I got in front of
myself a little bit
we played rook c8 uh he played rook a to
ca I played a3 this was a wasted move I
believe I was trying to stop his knife
from coming in so that I could push a c4
or wait a3 stop his knife from coming in
I go thinking about young c4 yeah
and I don't want to deal with I don't
want to deal with potentially losing my
rook over here and if he doesn't
exchange bringing his Bishop over to the
a file mm-hmm and my rook has nowhere to
go and so I'm like just going down and
there's already a look on the file so I
was just trying to hold that yeah well I
think you can probably just ignore the
Queen side for I should approach the I
should have stopped stormed I mean g4 is
risky but like so
if we go back a couple of months when I
before I did they the bishop to h2 I was
thinking of before that I was thinking
g4 mm-hmm he goes back to h7 I push into
g5 that's very policy I was looking at
this for a very strong moment and then
if he takes I take he takes my knight
potentially and then I got that pin on
his night he has nowhere to move the
knight actually yeah he can't take on e5
that's what I was thinking so I thought
okay that's safe guarded me but I was
already down I think I was down in my
20s in the guys what 16 yeah you were
taking a lot of time but I was listening
to my coach on the team so I kind of
like this Froy
I usually a position more imbalanced lot
sharper you have the G file which like
your King looks exposed but it's not
usually to your advantage like sit ready
- yeah move your king over and put their
work on g1 well you could move it to h2
instead of h1 I don't know oh yeah I
would actually I don't know because his
bishop if you want yeah no I like my
pawn on f3 actually it depends yeah if
you're gonna play a four then King is
probably safe on each - okay but yeah
this would have been interesting well
that's so that's the game I wanted to
play yeah and I don't know why I stopped
myself I take that I take it take and
then I move my Bishop to f3 potentially
awarded to d3 and when that that strong
she wanted yeah definitely take the
money yeah I don't wanna lose my bishop
and do we have to trade I would take his
bishop yep thank image - you would move
the King yeah I mean what else to do I
was looking at getting his Bishop off
the strong squares so oh like Bishop f3
Bishop to d3 it's possible and you have
you have Bishop d3 or Bishop f3 anytime
you want
meanwhile his bishops just staring into
blank space so I thought why not improve
the road oh I see
because very good point he goes Bishop
d3 and takes and goes make degree and by
CLE something like 27 wait in this
position
yes just like for example watch out at
black wants to like keep an eye on the
board because if you can plate 97 see
how I could go like the f5 these 60
before it takes a while though right so
once you trade the wait support bishops
right if you leave the minor pieces on
the board and let you know kind of
maneuver around for a while I don't know
I kind of like probably from a
positional standpoint maybe it's okay
for I feel like his King spoke with
those people like it's like for 10 B
yeah like mm yeah and if I just leave it
there for a minute you see how it's also
going to cover g7 gonna be useful and in
the meantime I though rotate c8 and then
seat a keyboard or something well so
this is this is a Dimitri way of playing
just so calm so I don't know huge - yeah
yeah we go over to G want more than 5
yeah yeah the Knights actually gonna
backfire but the Knights also gonna be
fine that's true why am I not doubling
the rooks and owning that maybe we'll
even sack someday g7 or even go like
sometimes when you double up rooks you
want to just go for stage fun yep
but I'm even looking at a sack right
this is really strange
so we're streaming I think from this
screen that we're streaming
Oh someone koala but the chat is
completely empty which is never the case
well I mean they see my face they're
very scared they're running away
yeah it's true I'm very Russian
suggesting I know what's going on
two other people are streaming including
Fiona mm-hmm they're like super popular
so that's why no one's really oh we have
one common Kiyomi H one of my biggest
fans
okay
okay yes I mean okay this would have
been more fun like I would have had this
would again this is one of my type of
games and I just did not play into it I
don't know why right now I can see his
black hazel looming because you played
b3 and black you know his name improved
version simplex threats are more like
white wants to play aggressive black
wants to play position right so I can
see why you're taking precautions going
like a three on the Queen side yeah
because it's scary but yeah if you don't
but I can just take and go Bishop 83 and
what I thought was I was a threat and I
thought it was Lear luring him over to
the Queen side with his pieces so that I
can go and just I've not even give two
hoots over on the Queen side I'm trying
not to swear on your stream so you
didn't play g4 no so I played Bishop 2h
- I think g4 would have been in g4 what
did what a stock fish or what a one of
those things say so let's guess stock
fish will probably say some move like
Bishop h2 okay but I don't know let's
see oh and they take c6 I mean stockfish
just likes black just cuz blacks PSR I
was looking I was looking at knight c6
and then g4 as well you were looking at
what knight c6 Knight takes and then g4
and then there are my knight on e5 but I
liked it there exactly and especially if
I was planning on going in pawn store me
I'd rather have all the pieces to my
advantage
yeah that's very typical and so yeah
like my game too I just put mine on 85
like leave it there and causes so many
issues yeah so I just felt very strained
here I thought I was playing like a
Carol Connor like we couldn't see what
soccers thinks about g4 I mean g4 is a
very human move which computer like does
it is not scared you guys have no fear
take take from a human standpoint this
is much easier to play for a white
because your ideas are so
straightforward like yes to get the G
file
meanwhile black is not really mmm having
so what's your plan but what is it
it's saying Queen c7
I mean I play at four yeah if the top
move is work excited just know humans
gonna feel comfortable here for about
right okay
well similar interesting lesson learned
there were some other cool fun stuff
that I thought through thoroughly I felt
proud of myself even though I lost
because my time good so you know I
notice that yeah so I mean I was going
pretty deep I think I was trying to
count myself down to like six or seven
move across three different scenarios I
see and that was what I was like that
was my metric that I was targeting can I
do that and maintain that for all the
tough situations and I felt comfortable
because there was moments where he
clearly didn't see the sixth or the
fifth move right and so I won a pawn in
the other game and he just didn't see
what and I felt very proud of that
moment yeah when you play games like
this you'll start realizing that like
players rated over 2,000 are still they
still have deficiencies in their play
right so right okay so a c8 I played 83
he played see take D for CT for okay I
played C take D for ya most of the time
in the London you want to take back with
a pawn but I thought if I was doing that
but then c3 sweetie so that I thought c3
was extremely weak he would take on e5 I
would take baths actually true and and
I'm very worried about his Bishop coming
in with the rook maintaining it and
winning that be pawn as well yeah yeah
this issue is playing b3 earlier but
this is okay like maybe you get before
it some pointers that was my intention
was to try and do that so Knight takes
e5 d take E 5 Knight to d7 he did not
see that I was gonna take with the pawn
that was nice I saw he was very computo
cuz he was ready to finish up C to me
and he thought and so he thought I was
gonna take with the bishop
I played b4 b4 and then this is question
mark question mark for me a 5 mm-hmm I
didn't think it was the strongest move
he had so I mean it it's very atypical
break given the setup and blacks
position so I thought I thought
as white squared bishop was very strong
so I did a move to try and blockade it
so I put my pawn on to e4
so sacrifice sacrifice but for position
and breathing room the problem is when
he took with partner yes
no no no no no no he took with bishop
okay similar the problem is if the
position opens up like his rooks are
well placed so when the D file opens up
there's gonna be more pressure
understand it's not worth giving away a
pawn for probably you want to hold on to
material so what would have been a good
pointer is a queen to be my first
impression is to play b5
so that's right that's what I was
thinking through and I thought he wins
it back how did I see he won of that do
you have a floor at some point maybe he
has this annoying move but yes so I
thought it was Bishop over my Queen to
e1 right forced and then I thought that
he just would do one here I did see this
is it Bishop back to a bishop or so this
is one of the points I think for white I
don't know if he's actually threatening
to tick because you have rook b1 uh-huh
this pin is pretty medicine and then the
rook up like rook c5 84 how can he go
8-4 like okay let's imagine let's
imagine you play an a3 which is you want
to get your Knight to g4 yeah he takes
yep
you know my rope here to hold it got it
yeah and you're you're winning the
bishop because it's pinned it's attacked
twice he could defend it once but they
you know they for okay and then he would
take the bishop most likely right or
yeah actually things got traded he might
make some material I think he wins
material here take yeah I take any two
rows and my bishop is stuck on h2 you
don't want to take the bishop you want
to take the pollen d7 okay and then if
we count material he has a rook and
Bishop for the clean material well if
I'm looking at the situation I also have
to free my bishop on h2 that's true so I
just feel like I'm down but this is a
good scenario for you you want his queen
I can immediately
to make my night right but your night is
good you might come exactly a bishop can
come back to f4 your king will have
breathing room yeah his pieces are
passive like his Bishop on e7 doing
nothing or looks very active
this is preferable no I like I like
where you went with that b5 it looks
overextending it looks weakening but
yeah it's kind of a must listen and I
thought I was one of my grandmasters
okay so and I wanted him to take with
the pawn it surprised me that he took
with the bishop so I was actually half
because that Bishop had been annoying me
all game oh and after you for yeah so I
was actually happy that he was still
interesting because this pause week so
he took with Bishop you take yeah and
then I was able to pull a little bit of
tactics here so I I actually did this
entire scenario down to this level so he
took with the pawn my Queen went over t1
and then he took the pawn I took the
pawn his Queen took I took his Queen his
Bishop took and then I was like aha
rook to a a so I was wondering did you
consider rook to e1 I did or even rook
rook a v1 as I thought you might want to
win this pawn is first cuz it says this
one is kind of weak okay but I don't
know so I didn't think so
I thought his rook oh maybe this year he
has Bishop c3 I think that that's I was
looking at these lines yeah but this
would my life would have been a lot
smoother I think this way actually I
don't know cuz he wins e5 right but I
take his Bishop and I or his night and
I'm feeling a little bit more secure
well you're down to pawns yeah but
they're all constrained to one side of
the board right the this is black in
full control yeah fives coming his rook
surrogate oh you know why I didn't like
this one is that his knight came to e3
and or d3 in the end I don't know why
that that annoyed yeah d3 is for the
post and then like I would have his
right off the bishop and then yes he's
winning as soon as I had to exchange so
maybe rotate for best move I really did
enjoy it yeah I felt powerful
he went from like 60 minutes on his
clock down to 20 okay 35 on this that's
pretty yeah I was very happy with this
yeah the position like it's a little bit
better for
but if you can neutralize the b-pawn
juanique on it should be whole double I
think was 35 minutes yeah so anyway like
I just felt like I got back a little bit
of breathing room for this one so he
ended up going to Bishop to c3 mm-hmm to
try and win it I took he pushed to g5
which surprised me g5 and I and here's
where I made a mistake
I went to I went h4 h4 I thought I had
an opportunity here when he gave me
tempo and I should have leveraged it a
little bit better but I think I saw that
Sam had lost or something like that at
this point and I was just like trying to
win oh yes I went from I went from
trying to like yeah you still be equal
like you can play too
yeah and so here I thought I can pull
some moves like he'll go for my pawn
I'll go for his King and I've got two
bishops so I I thought I had some
snipers yeah I mean that the bishops
could be effective later exactly and
that's what I was intending to you know
move move f3 bring in moved my king out
move to a bishop to g1 and free it along
the powerful line it takes a while I
think I ended up doing it it just was
too late yeah I mean h4 typical break I
just don't know if it does anything
right here round so let's take a look at
other options
yeah the first move that comes to mind
is just for you one if you can improve a
piece with tempo it's usually a
no-brainer
he would probably defend some fo maybe
route C 7 I was actually thinking like
g5 was intended to prevent yeah exactly
but I was thinking you should put out a
4 right oh yes yes I was looking at that
well maybe he just ignores it and does
something else like 95 or something
the tricky night though actually you
know what he has my c5 in this position
it's uncomfortable for white the problem
at this position is your pieces are just
not on great squares yeah this Bishop
super passive this rooks inactive
especially doing nothing this works tied
down to the palm
compliment me a little bit more yeah but
it's a type of position where if you can
realize forum and the order and like
things open up on the kingside then so
my my intention this moment was get my
king active as well yeah in the center I
heard that from somebody last night they
Michael
so so that's what I was trying to do so
I went here I think he brought his let's
see what he did so I went age 41 might
see five you might see five might see
fun yeah that might see that's good
I went Rock G for I was thinking about
rook to c4 but I didn't like where that
was heading because then he could just
push the pawn rook g4 it looks good yeah
I thought this was okay let's see so I
had 14 minutes 47 seconds at this point
rook d2 he had 28 minutes due to I
immediately went Bishop f3 to try and
earn back some time rope to d4 he was
resourceful it was like he's kind of
stuck on the Kings side was creating
counter play yep and then rook e1 is
what I went through and I don't know if
that was the right move or not but I
thought it was so I thought it was
pretty sharp and then this way I can
with my king to f1 you know I mean you
could try to like get initiative like
you want to keep the initiative here and
get deep improving with initiative so
maybe one way to do that is to take okay
today was take here
yeah you take he takes and then you play
back for also a commission okay
and the goal still just open lines for
your piece against like if I was worried
about him just pushing it I was worried
about him just pushing and letting me
take it because we're going to be funny
yeah what damages that is this well this
is what you're hoping for it to get some
activity on the Kings side let's say he
pushes again okay oh you don't have you
six immediately
maybe have bishop here you're just
trying to poke him I understand
and if he continues to go b3 yep the
thing is like if your Bishop Everest can
become a blocker there yeah that's a
good point and and my black Bishop is
not actually your rook is covering b1
okay
yes black still has to work to promote
let's say you play g6 okay his King goes
to f8 t f8 in this position you don't
think so
oh no that would be a job yeah yeah so
he would have to push past push just
leave it alone no if he pushes a fun you
either like that five you take on two
songs oh yeah yeah I'm super strong
there oh wow counter click how did I
miss this
that's not something you miss is
something that you kind of understanding
you're making threats you have
initiative so like take take this is
maybe most likely what would happen this
one okay and that's the benefit of
having the bishop here especially when
there's pawns on yeah guides you yes use
your Bish's that's kind of a
multi-purpose piece okay so and so no no
keep going with this one cuz I mean I
mean there's there's Chancellor's for
both sides now yeah
Black's still probably better but
there's yeah I don't know there's fights
so okay all right let's go back oh gosh
I can't believe I and I looked at that
too I looked it up for a lot a lot of
different times because it's interesting
how quickly you build up initiative like
which is with your bishops yep okay you
play rugby one yeah yes in that position
could be one
Meechum city rook takes was your home's
name so cake
narayana and eight are aya and a and
Rishi
okay so rook take G for Bishop take G
for and then Bishop to D for King f1
okay so what I was worried about with if
I didn't move my king was his knight
coming in and harassing that Athlon yeah
that's true
so where did I go King f1 let me find it
rook b8 h takes g5 h takes g5 rook to b5
b6 bishop d1 so this is a question one
for me I moved this really fast I don't
know if it was the best b1 I mean your
bishops doing nothing on g4 yeah so I
thought I would actively attempted to
improve this bishop faster f4 well I was
worried about here was I worried about
maybe taking 93 take in the 93 I was
worried about that night move
yeah it's true I think like your your
defender yeah exactly so I think I could
have done that and you're thinking is
not you're ready to play I mean that's
so much easier when you can see it on
the board instead of in your head and in
time can control your inside pressure
that stuff you guys said this was gonna
be fun to come out of retirement
we have not yet had any experience
retiring from chess so start taking a
step back this is a 2,000 player I
haven't played like professionally in a
tournament right properly for 12 years I
felt pretty damn good about myself
no you put up a fight yeah you mean I
made him work for it you you came up
with some resourceful moves
okay so so where were we at rook to b5
b6 bishop d1 Knight to f6 96 yes so he
was planning to go - yep - c7 I played
f3 okay what I'm trying to do here is
I'm trying to control the white squares
when his Knight does get active and need
to help go push that pawn down meanwhile
I was whenever he releases the pressure
on that epon I get to move my h2 Bishop
out and finally I just want ideas
exactly so that's where I was at with
that mindset
night night c7 wrote to b4 oh sorry
I thought you were looking at it's good
Bishop c5 rooked our sorry rook to g4
and I don't know if this was the best
move Bishop e7 uh-huh so I was happy
with that but I wasn't sure if my move
was the best move at the time yeah
Bishop to g1 oh so you don't go after
the Jeep off I was thinking about it I
thought maybe a Porsche for her or I was
thinking Bishop f4 but then I thought he
had ideas around Knight to d5 take it
okay one back your five doesn't know I
thought I was really worried about the
fork on e3 but he doesn't have it
covered
yeah yeah I should have done it and your
Bishop comes to b3 where's puck hitting
the beep on that's still better with a
knight but it should be a draw quick-dry
why are you this good oh gosh
alright it's just a skill happens all
right moving up so I did not do that if
we can go back so I went Bishop to G one
g1 Knight to d5 yeah that was your one
opportunity to win the Jeep on yes
Bishop to b3 King H 287 oh sorry yes
King aged seven king e - so should I
take it the night do you think
I think so because what I was worried
about was getting my rook back in time
to hold well you have a bishop - you
have a king and you you weaken his pond
so like all the pot all the black cards
are potential weaknesses yes
so maybe maybe a little too easy yes
with this part yeah
and he moves to hold a the only way to
defend it
she might get good move and then rock
down but maybe then you just play like
rook yes exactly exactly and then I know
I'm attacking five then you do this oh
yes Alicia yeah I don't know I don't
know if thinking was the best so I
didn't do that yeah I mean black spider
and all nice lines
Bishop to b3 king h2 arts art museum
yeah he's so king to e2 Knight to Knight
G to F for check so he was just trying
to put pressure on me after all the
results were starting to come in yeah
King to d2 rook to d8 he had a lot of
tricks here with his Knight
so I was just trying to avoid them
Knights are tricky yeah so he went hook
to d8 Chuck King - see - and then rook
c8 check I went to king b1 okay and
finally king h6 yeah I mean White's just
worse so I did kind of stuck and then I
did a really bad move here I did a 3 or
sorry a g3 yeah I thought I didn't think
that went through but I did too fast I
was under five minutes at this point why
is that bad
night came to harass each my bishop yep
and I was worried about him bringing his
rook down Oh Rexy one yeah live with it
Bishop f2 so it was a baby I went so
rook F or Bishop F to rook c3 is what he
did instead we're at c3 yeah I didn't
see that one he's just winging the pond
yeah so then Bishop C - I don't like to
give free games away so I was at least
trying to maintain
if he screws up rook takes f3 Bishop
takes b8 these yep b6 r 8b 6
I can't read more on 6 rook takes g3
okay rook c4 down two pawns Knight c3
check I thought he might have made some
mistakes with his night here so King b2
that's why I didn't give up right away
Knight to d5 and then this is what I
kind of knew that it was over right this
moment when he didn't bring it on state
you know you keep fighting like he has a
way that's gonna win this is by pushing
the pawns exactly and then you have to I
was trying to like him more and more can
any of that so be so 95 I went BC 5 well
I started going I saw him going night to
e3 to fork my bishop anyways well maybe
that's is that what you're hoping for
let's so you play Bishop g4 Kenny plays
mighty treatment you play or exceed okay
but let's take a step back he doesn't
have to do that right so without that so
if I went too deep Bishop c4 now his
Knight
what can he do so I was looking at
Bishop check at a3 focus paid 3 actually
this is scary and then night sight
before check you know you're getting
massacred here like but you can't go
tonight
oh yeah Ritchie wants okay King b1 you
know I figure out yep yeah like this is
what you're hoping for just yes exactly
some some silly thing what your Bishop
far away yes yes that's so you nailed it
but you know at the end of the day I
these are all the things that I was
looking at I thought I had more chances
with a with a skewer or a fork later
so Bishop c5 Bishop takes e5
Bishop c5 wait
we went back a little too far King to be
295
be c5 Bishop c5 Bishop takes e5 rook
takes e5 wrote to e3
Bishop F
I just trying to throw them off rook
takes e5 I don't think we have to go any
further okay okay yeah food Oh
people are talking okay striptease in
the background okay thanks guys for
watching that was not interactive at all
but hopefully people learn something
maybe I'll be back in the future with
better games ah see ya there's finally
viewers too bad we're ending now I end
this stop screaming